the Trump administration just fired the
first shots in a looming trade war with
China at one minute after midnight
Eastern Time the u.s. raised tariffs on
thirty four billion dollars worth of
Chinese goods the president says that
number will increase to 50 billion
dollars in two weeks China's foreign
ministry responded saying retaliatory
tariffs on US goods are now in place
without giving details Face the Nation
moderator and CBS News senior foreign
affairs correspondent Margaret Brennan
is with us from Washington Margaret good
morning good morning well Anthony
Beijing now calls this the largest
economic trade war in history and
they're blaming the Trump administration
for starting it so those tariffs you
just laid out are really seen by them as
an opening shot in this war we are not
seeing a breakthrough so far we are only
seeing escalation even though the
president had promised that this
pressure campaign would lead to more
deals better deals it's only led to
escalation at this point and that really
has a number of people who would
normally be supporters of the president
Republican senators particularly from
the US heartland business leaders really
concerned and in fact the Federal
Reserve said just yesterday they're
hearing from American businesses that
they're already pulling back spending
because they're worried this could get
worse what exactly is the administration
hoping to accomplish with these tariffs
well according to the president's stated
intent this is to get China to stop
stealing intellectual property and to
stop over producing metals like steel
and dumping them onto the market which
they say artificially hurts pricing but
that's not what these tariffs are really
aimed at were the retaliatory tariffs
here they're really inflicted to to add
pain and so far that is what we are
hearing from people in American farmland
and that's what we're going to be
speaking this weekend to some of the
senators on the program including
senator Joni Ernst about Margaret
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo is of
course in Pyongyang to continue talks on
denuclearization on the peninsula what
the expectation there in terms of the
outcome well he says he's gonna spend
the next day and a half really trying to
fill in the blanks on that verbal
agreement that he says was made between
President Trump and Kim jong-un but so
far North Korea has not even provided a
list of the weapons that they have in
their arsenal and that's the first step
in the disarmament process that the
National Security Advisor John Bolton
told us about on Face the Nation this
weekend he said that would take about a
year so we're seeing very little
progress but president Trump indicated
yesterday he's willing to be patient up
to a point because he sees
confidence-building measures like North
Korea taking down some of their
propaganda Margaret Brennan thank you
Margaret